[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys
ryan may back in the seat over here
what's up
i have to say anthony thank you so
[ __ ] much right now because that
right there
that is like child gold
[Laughter]
that sounds funny i could do it i could
do without the wrap on the outside yeah
saying what else would you have like the
machine i think you want a jabbawockee
mask i just put a trash bag over frankly
yeah or maybe like some non-shim noodles
or something that appreciates nothing
she really just went out the door
immediately like it's like gratitude
gone we were just uh playing that [ __ ]
and
i just couldn't stop myself from like
smiling in the sounds and like
everything that we were playing we
played double dragon [ __ ] ninja
turtle street fighter and some lame ass
bowling game that they pulled out
dude
when i showed up you guys were playing
turtles in time which is like
dude i got that game for my birthday
when i was like i don't know a
seven-year-old kid lucky ass
[ __ ] that's a nice birthday i'll
never forget right like my my mom comes
in the room and they give me this
present with my dad right and then i'm
like oh no it's for the super nintendo
we don't have a super nintendo and then
we go downstairs and they got us a super
fun guy
so they knew they knew it was yeah
that's so bad i thought they [ __ ] up
and i was like oh no you know what i
mean my parents would do that though
they would buy the game and you're just
like [ __ ] i can't play this on this game
yep that's so good that is like dope i
literally just got chills from that yeah
but that was like my first game i ever
played done
on the super nintendo and yeah it was i
mean that's the soldiers all the way
through the roof great first game for
super nintendo oh yeah what was
everybody's like main first childhood
arcade game not necessarily first but
like your [ __ ] arcade
not like uh nintendo like
arcade at the arcade with the quarters
ninja turtles oh yeah ninja turtles yeah
yeah you know what was really good was a
simpsons game yeah the simpsons game is
that game in there i think so i think oh
i don't [ __ ] with my emotions dog
[ __ ] i'd rather tell you it's not there
that that's the case
like your parents i'd rather just fight
her and uh is it metal slug you're like
metal you get to jump in a little tank
we got every metal slug on that nba jam
is that gonna be a jam i bet it does
we gotta play nba jam yeah jam so they
had what like every game from neo geo
every game from geo geo maine genesis
nintendo super nintendo so it has four
player nba jam then huh oh what wow
we're not going home tonight boys we're
gonna stay this is home
[Laughter]
exactly
it's the zoning in this area
i think uh i think for me was also metal
slug was one of those games and then
also uh it was either a puzzle puzzle
fighter puzzle fight i don't want to say
bubble bobble but that was the nintendo
version that i was playing yeah yeah but
puzzle fighter with the street fighter
characters i remember that being like
the sickest [ __ ] when it first came out
never played that before how does that
go it's like a tetris thing but with
like gems like squares but this the
street fighter characters are like
little kind of like cartoon big head
bubble versions that are on the side and
then when you do like a major tetris
style combo yeah they [ __ ] shoot
hadoukens and stuff yeah so fun marvel
vs capcom hell
yeah said where's capcom that's the one
where you get to have three players that
you choose three fighters right and you
can swap them in whenever you want or
you can like press the double button
they come and just do like a special
attack and come back out just when we
were kids it's like dude who would [ __ ]
who up spiderman wolverine and it's like
you get to play it [ __ ] fantasy yeah
it's true
were you able to get sailor moon what
the [ __ ] are you talking about right now
you might be thinking about chun li no
no no there was one where you're able to
bring it you're able to bring in a
sailor moon and everyone brought that
one in because she comes and kills you
like you get to see up her skirt a
little bit what
all of us would like get her to come in
i feel like you're making this up nah
dude
once because you had a [ __ ] weird
video game fantasy doesn't mean it
happened at all the rest of us
you get wolverine right you get
wolverine and he goes berserker
yeah that's right yeah yeah he does get
to have like sailor moon cyclops or a
[ __ ] hulk and then say a little bit
you're talking about chun li bro
we should just [ __ ] character in that
that looks like sailor moon
no dude you can't be doing steve jones
dude come on you can't be doing steve
jobs this doesn't wait we can't do that
on on on on youtube right no there's a
uh there's a sailor moon one you got to
set it up
you can't just drop the punch the visual
punchline like that without setting it
up
you gotta help us you gotta show me
first
and then iron this guy's just gonna
start showing naked pictures of people
without any saying anything he just
turns the screen around more naked
pictures
that's a steve
you guys don't remember there's a sailor
moon or something this will say he's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing
is there not you're really searching for
it i was searching for it but then the
second salem cosplay stuff turned off is
sailor moon part of capcom no uh she's
not in any of the marvel capitals okay
there's something called capcom
all-stars versus sailor moon
let me see
what that's oh it's a mugen it's not
it's a it's a mod
but maybe if you show it to me i'm not i
swear to god you're telling us there's a
there's a game where sailor moon flashes
her underwear to everybody no i should i
mean she has her clothes on but she
comes in and [ __ ] like zaps everyone
but there's wolverine in there there's
[ __ ] ryu there's always it's chun li
dude who the [ __ ] do you think chun li
is
i
that's what it was that's what it was no
i'd [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] literally any of you
guys up button mashing mortal kombat 2.
there's mortal kombat there too yeah
dude dude how many games are on there
over 2 000 you got to be kidding me how
do you search for them you got to type
in the name so it goes first by like the
place play system so it's either like
nintendo super nintendo genesis maim
neogeo or whatever this is the whole
roster is that any one of these people i
think they have some of the games that
we're on in 64. um and so then you go
into
which could be her and then from there
it shows alphabetical order the the
games all right who's this [ __ ] anime
looking [ __ ] over here
she's got half her titties out with
green hair morrigan morgan that is
standard move bro i don't know some
[ __ ] anime looks like they're all
japanese
who's this anime in this world
racist asian i know look at this [ __ ]
pirate chick with their tits all out
yeah is that sailor moon [ __ ] yes
most of the characters got their tits
out yeah i like how bart is supporting
his case by not showing us sailor moon
but yeah look at this
look at his chick dude
there's so many girls with titties
that's spiderman
girls kind of got titties though that's
spider-man spider-man
does it have dream cast it could have
been morgan no they're not they're not
like that because morgan kind of looks
like they're like the
total arcade yeah but they have nintendo
and all the genesis and at-home [ __ ] i
feel like the rk in the nintendo super
nintendo era they did a lot more of like
uh cross-platform games crosston gaming
because there were only so many games
out at the time right how did you find
that thing i feel like me and mike
looked up on craigslist to be honest we
were just like we [ __ ] won an arcade
and then we looked on craigslist and
then it was one of those things where
it's like
2965 games for like 2 500 bucks or
something right and the original casing
on that or usually they saw them in just
two player controllers right and then
we're like no we gotta [ __ ] find a
four player one because yeah we have to
have more people because and i remember
us talking specifically about teenage
mutant ninja turtles he's like you can't
[ __ ] play teenage mutant ninja
turtles or x-men
without all that children
because i used to play street fighter by
myself right it's like one versus one
and i can never get past the first level
because i suck at video games
but all four of us all four turtles i
felt bad for the bad guys the foot
soldiers we were just [ __ ] beating
the [ __ ] out of here we were jumping
them bro yeah we're straight jumping all
the bad guys non-stop that was so tight
you become the bad guys after you hit we
went through four levels in like five
minutes
we're just beating the [ __ ] out of
everybody well it changes the narrative
of the game and the foot clan has no
training at all so it's just a wipeout
anyway i mean the foot clan are just
acting we were beating up high school
kids yeah for sure yeah the foot clan
are just juvenile delinquents with no
[ __ ] fight training
daddy issues that's why the foot clan
when you guys were playing street
fighter did the moves come back to you
like it was slowly starting to come back
but i forgot all the [ __ ] down left
something is hadouken is like riding a
bicycle you know sonic boom is left
right uh [ __ ] punch yeah it's like
bam that's not trying to do it i
couldn't get that circle
hold back two seconds front slip with
you guys play with me bro i'll spam
[ __ ] doll seam [ __ ] i'll spam that
[ __ ] the whole goddamn match i don't
give a [ __ ]
dude there's a game uh there's a
dreamcast game i remember it was like a
fighting game and like it was dead or
alive dead or alive and all the chicks
had super bouncy tits yes they had like
boob physics literally programmed for
this there was another one that everyone
talked about still it was a fighting
game and i remember there was a guy
named kilk or some [ __ ] and he had both
soul calibur soul calibur bro
i will [ __ ] spam the bo staff this
move the entire [ __ ] make magic from
like just doing random button presses in
that game it's insane do you remember a
killer instinct oh i love that game that
one took some skill man who's the guy
that looks like predator oh full gore
yeah that guy oh he got it right so
there actually is a character that looks
like
foreigner but i only thought about that
because of the bouncing booth things
because there's like a fatality type
thing at the end where the girl with the
boobs she turns around just shows your
boot her boobs and then you die and then
the guy
yeah it just [ __ ] explodes or
something but i hated that she turned
around i was like that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you can't even see it an age
well yeah every single time she turns on
i still went like this yeah i think the
2d screen was going to [ __ ] show
machine you're all gluing yourself to
the screen dude if there was internet
back then you know what we would have
been doing right we would've been
telling the developers they're [ __ ]
idiots because she turned the wrong way
this guy's messed up you guys are so
stupid she's not even facing the right
direction
no the only fans if you pay another
quarter you get to see the side
smart
today's video is brought to you by
blender's eyewear as you can see i have
my own eyewear but is it blenders it's
not you know what it's pretty dangerous
too because what's gonna happen if i'm
riding down the street and i get into an
accident oh no there's an old lady bam i
didn't see her because she's so small
crack my glasses like that
and it's all the ways those glasses cost
me three thousand dollars man it was
designer
from a man at the swap meet he told me
that it was made from a mayan
designer's
bare hands
from the mayan times now if you're an
active person or someone
who doesn't like to buy expensive ass
sunglasses or glasses and you want
something a little bit more affordable
but still fashionable and stylish well
blender's eyewear has the answers for
you it's pretty freaking awesome it's
created by this dude named chase fisher
from straight out of our backyard san
diego california and he himself is a
surfer and he said
you know what i'm always losing my
sunglasses i'm tired of spending 500
bucks all the time i'm doing all these
activities they get cracked they get
messed up
man if only there was mid-priced eyewear
out there so i could go ahead and still
do this without worrying about what's in
my eyes while it's protecting me from
the sun rays and i think that blenders
achieve this because i'm super excited
they got some cool options they're
sending me a couple and i can't wait to
put them on so i could go out there and
potentially crack my face with them and
they don't only just have sunglasses
they have pretty cool reading glasses
prescription eyewear and snowboard
season is coming up and they have
goggles so live life forward in motion
with blenders today go to
www.blender's eyewear
and for 15 off put in our promo code
because we're hooking you up okay and
our promo code is off the record vip so
that's blenderseyewear.com
put in our promo code off the record vip
for 15
off without further ado we're gonna go
right back to the video okay
get him
me and my sister um my parents were we
were in cyprus you remember in cyprus
where the nickel nickel was oh hell yeah
it's gonna be nicole nicole before it
was a nickel nickel it was called
western arcade remember that i don't
that's way well well four doors down
from that in that plaza was something
called diamond cleaners these were dry
cleaners that's my parents dry cleaners
i remember in the same plaza the same
plaza so literally i think i've been in
that plot the luckiest kid on earth yeah
there's albert tacos there's a master
lube um there's a kfc yeah there's
albert tacos yeah yeah yeah and a bank
of america anyways so um is alpha valley
view it is valid on lincoln let's go
back you guys grew up in the same city
it's kind of like close enough cerritos
is close enough yeah i'll just cereals
all the time for sure too cyprus that's
the city you grew up i wasn't i was
growing up in my hometown is buena park
but i went to sunny hills high school in
fullerton but like fullerton born to
park cyprus cerritos like you're always
there's only a [ __ ] four town centers
and two malls so you have to like kind
of yeah look like the sgv over here it's
like people know people from rosemead
monterey park alhambra whatever it's
like it's like that it's like those
cluster cities point is there was a
western arcade right next to our dry
cleaner so my sister and i would always
go over there as kids and you would
always [ __ ] try to like sneak behind
the machines like there was like island
of machines that were back-to-back as
kids we would try to slide back there
because you knew that people dropped
quarters every single day yeah right and
every day if you were willing to hide
from the [ __ ] worker in the in the
arcade and we were just a little ass kid
so nobody ever really cared you just
shove your arm down get super dirty and
stuff but we've always found maybe like
two dollars and fifty cents in quarters
a day you missed a lot back then yeah
yeah all every day we played for free
until finally i got addicted to the
off-road game right oh yeah yeah this is
the worst this is the worst stealing
i've ever done
i got addicted to it because you can
never beat games unless you have
unlimited that's true because you're
programmed to ramp up after the first
level yeah it's just so [ __ ]
impossible right yeah so i got into this
flow where you know under cash registers
there's that silent little thing
underneath if you flick it to the right
if the cashier opens without going ding
anyways it's
consumer [ __ ] i don't know these things
i don't know these things so okay so
that was the way that you would go in
without like alerting anybody that the
cashier was opening so you know you
start slow i start stealing quarters at
a time but you can't [ __ ] win a game
by stealing quarters at a time so the
first time you steal like a dollar and
you have to change your recorders that's
a whole new jump but then the difference
in the size of a paper from a dollar to
a five is really no different so you get
a little bolder you like move your hand
over to like the different segments
finally out bold enough i stole a 20. i
turned all 20 dollars into quarters
at your at your work at your mom's place
oh no we took the 20 went to the the
change machine right i don't want to
[ __ ] keep resetting going back just
in case the timer so i take all 20
dollars in quarters and put it all in at
once holy [ __ ] all the ones so i have
as a kid you're like infinite credits
baby i'm going i'm going to win this
game
and after i put all of it i play for
like five minutes and then my dad's like
hey we gotta go
no [ __ ] did you have a pocket full of
no it's already painted in the machine
already already in the machine and i
thought this is the worst what about the
glowing red button you can't push it and
get it you can't you literally just
unload all the coins every quarter i
have to say as far as crimes go you
reinvesting it into this business is
like
you're literally like stealing from the
register and then putting it in their
game anyway
i'm seeing it from my dry cleaners
register oh i thought you were stealing
from the arcade no i want to steal from
the arcade you're doing it for your
family bro yes yes it was the worst
stuff is how old were you probably six
seven it's good for your family
but i wasn't thinking about the morals i
was thinking about the fact that i put
it every [ __ ] quarter of twenty
dollars and within like 75 cents of
usage my dad said hey we gotta go dude
if i told my dad that i stole that 20
and then it's in this machine he'd be
like well you better get the [ __ ]
value all right
all right play it through play through
first your dad does things like speak
english and how many 20s did you take at
120 oh i thought you took like all the
20s in the register same feeling when
you're [ __ ] seven years old it's 80
credits right it's four quarters yeah in
super off-road is that you can pay money
to upgrade the car as well you're like
you use yeah so you can get better tires
so like you know as you drive on this
dirt road you can like run into like
little items you get points oh is that
the one that goes nitro yes i remember
that you know why don't you ask for a
refund
as a kid you don't have that long
because if you push you know if you push
the uh you know the coin dispenser red
part in yeah would they have come out it
does it didn't it did it not every
single game did that dude do you think
the next kid who walked up to like
thank you yeah i know except i don't
think it was kid i think there's nothing
with other grown-ass men in that arcade
all the time we were i was like i was
like i'm the kid here
yeah can you play that game on on this
one yes oh did i get my 20 worth
eventually yes
did you beat it did you ever beat it
[ __ ] it no it takes forever is it
unbeatable
it's just an infinite loop did you
that's the price make 20 bucks and put
it back in the register
you son of a [ __ ] i bet you did it you
got to do that tonight yeah go to your
[ __ ] parents leaders put a 20 in
their damn register with inflation
because you know what i did i [ __ ]
sold drugs and put money into my mom's
purse i never [ __ ] took from her i
i am disappointed in you
you are definitely better than me i like
that joe involved his parents in a drug
crime
and that makes him better he's
laundering money for his parents mom
yeah you don't take from them being in
laundry you let them collude with you on
a drug crime you don't take them they're
an accessory now very nice let them
collude i should have done that you got
a clue with your parents did you were
did you you should have stole from the
arcade not stole from your parents did
they ever find out that you sold you
took the 20 out your return yeah i think
parents are are like i honestly
guarantee they like knew and just like
chose to
not say anything yeah or punish me in a
different way yeah that's why your dad
was like all right let's go cause like
you know as a kid you're always just
kind of like two just watches have gone
away with that one but like at the same
time it's like you knew you were [ __ ]
doing it
and like old school mama and pop shops
they probably run a balance at the end
of the day right like this is how much
cash every shop every single day
how often would you even see 20s at the
laundromat well there would be 20s
because like that's like the highest
bill people would ever pay with and it's
not like you know people don't do 20
with the laundry but i think it's just
more the idea that in your mind as a kid
you think you're getting away with
something but it's like if you [ __ ]
just count the cash at the end of the
day you're gonna know something's
missing you notice because you kept
taking the one and the five and the
twenty i remember when i was stealing my
dad's condoms right i'll steal my dad's
condoms and he probably had like
seven eight of them and i remember
thinking like dude if i take like two
he's not gonna notice right meanwhile
flash forward i grow up and i think
myself i play a pack of like 10 20
condoms and i'm like i would [ __ ]
notice if suddenly some condoms were
missing do you think your dad ever went
in there and he's like he's like
i have been getting hella laid you know
i've been [ __ ]
no
[ __ ] [ __ ] no but if he steals them
back from you
all of those things caused so many
marital problems like stolen condoms was
like from the wife like stolen money was
like your dad was being accused of it
and they were [ __ ] arguing and you
had no idea that's true and have them
collude with drug sales
your mom's like i bought those condoms
jeremy i know how many we have
jeremy
i'd be so funny they're just linked in
his dress like first the condoms down
the 20s
to the wrong order
did you use those condoms though were
you six when you stole those two
[Laughter]
because you have to learn yeah yeah
it's not stealing when you first do it i
stole 30 bucks from my mom when i was
like i think nine or ten because that's
fifty percent more than mine
i stole a lot no i just never stole from
family bro i stole it from my mom
everyone everyone had a walkman and i
didn't have one uh so i was like [ __ ]
go get one and i was like oh yeah my mom
keeps money in her purse
so i took 30 bucks i went down to
thrifty's and i bought a walkman and i
remember my mom's like
have you seen my money i'm like no and
he goes where'd you get that from and i
was just like so innocent i was like i
stole it from your purse
i guess you're honest you're so innocent
dude you beat my ass
i stole it
first did she at least put on your
walkman while she beat your ass
played some mortal kombat music [ __ ]
kicked your ass
how old were you i think i was like 5
10. i was like in like fourth or fifth i
stole it from your partner
yeah you keep money there dude for 30
bucks you got the biggest piece of [ __ ]
walking i've ever heard about you still
got [ __ ] up
about that you get to keep the walkman
no well my mom locked it up she's like
she you know like my
my super religious uh upbringing so she
was like what are you doing listen to
this [ __ ] [ __ ] and should put it away
you should have been like i'm listening
to buddhist chants the buddhist church
you think if tigers stole a walkman that
you'd go to june you'd be like baby he
stole a walkman isn't that crazy
and he'd let him keep it because we know
that you don't punish yourself
yo where the [ __ ] did you find a walkman
at this day and age that's pretty cool
that that would be impossible to return
that to best buy next time you go there
okay
walks in the house with a walkman
that's pretty tight dude he's watching
laserdisc at home yeah no i got it like
moonwalker on laserdisc he's just a
guardian of the galaxy
star-lord i'm just impressed
good transition to cutting cameras bart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you